I read a Facebook post from my friend
the other day as she wrote god I wish I
was at Asian woman in the 1920s I love
the music then Asian woman in the 1920s
yup
[__] female rights racial persecution
yeah use your [__] head god damn it
oh you two now being an asian-american
there are constant types that we either
heard or grew up with and look I try not
to touch it too much on the subject
because I believe there are a lot of
people out there that try to milk this
topic cuz yeah we [__] get it how
dare you tell me I have no small I know
[__] but one stereotype that I never
really understood that I heard a lot of
non Asian people saying black people is
that Asian women are submissive and do
that I say what the [__] are you talking
about I want to understand we're in
today's society have you gotten the
stereotype what type of Asian one
minutes you have been and on top of that
I have dated a lot of Asian women and
they have either try to whup my ass what
were you trying to kill me did you have
any idea how strong Asian women are and
I'm not just talking about mentally I'm
talking about you physically how many
times that you got into a fun restaurant
and that that's talking about scuba
don't push the boat too hard and that
got you thinking like [__] [__]
these women had the ability to touch
flames comes up with the last time you
touch the hot coat with your bare hands
punk-ass [__] there are only two people
on earth that can touch that hot ball
without any consequences a beautiful
Asian woman and a human torch
many ancient American women such as my
mother had to work 70-plus our jobs
while still holding down the household
like eyeballs my mother ran a business
make at Guam fed me kingi and still had
time to beat my [__] ass and if
that's not the definition of strength I
don't know what is you punk-ass [__] in
a dick what mama so strong somebody shot
a bullet at the one she caught that
bitching about legend I remember back in
the day she would beat me so hard I was
there singing The Lion King anthem just
for strength
yah shot
I swear a good part of white America's
image of Asian women was based on all
these [__] Hollywood movies in the
80s and you know what it's so funny
because those stereotypes still stick
today every time without fail it was
always as one little Japanese girl that
got amazed because one little white boys
put one word in her language
hey Tammy go arigato with that [__] they
say Karate Kid dumb ass quick son bender
Sundays listen if you're going to base
your perception of Asian women on a film
why not Crouching Tiger Hidden the
[__] Dragon those girls
what talk about budgets talking about
talking about boy dots oh yeah [__] you
that's ancient come food desert act I
call the week [__] yeah sup ha you're a
weak asian woman that patch that does
not work on let me ask you something why
didn't those movies as featured Asian
women talk about the women who busted
their ass coming to a foreign country
still somehow making a living for
themselves and their family while taking
care of everything else now but that
seems a little bit more realistic to me
I'm not even sure if a lot of you even
think about this men or women how many
of you can say that you can go to a
foreign country where they told you you
did not be long make a living survive
and not only that be successful at what
you're doing yeah not many of you right
and listen before a lot of you get
things twisted I don't have this thing
about don't date our Asian women this is
not what this video is about I don't
have any ties in telling somebody else
what ethnicity they should date I don't
give a [__] that's what weak insecure
possessive people say and let me tell
you something else this is America the
land of where you can place your penis
and your vagina wherever you want please
yeah but what I am saying is that if you
think that submission is an adjective
that goes along with Asian women my
friend you are in for a big surprise
okay the thing I'm gonna go tell one
Korean girl to do your laundry why'd you
end up with a chocolate of your ass and
the chili pepper up your scrotum see
that's a natural Korean defense move
it's called
we Bing pygar
now big an asian-american there are
constant stereotypes and stop at the
poppy yo look there were classes there
your ties the baby we grew up with but
but you don't want the boom